gzip a lossless file compression tool
famous for making large chunks of data
smaller the files on a computer are
represented by bits on a silicon chip
but they often take up more space than
is actually necessary for example when
you write your screenplay in a text
document you produce a bunch of repeated
patterns many years ago computer
scientists realized we were wasting
space and wrote algorithms like lz77 to
address this problem by looping over the
contents of a file to identify repeated
sequences that can be replaced with
metadata or shorter sequences thus
reducing the total amount of bits
required to represent the information
most importantly no information is lost
this differs from lossy compression
algorithms like jpeg which can make an
image file smaller but information is
lost in the process gzip was developed
by jean-luc guys and mark alder in 1992
because the big evil tech corporations
held the patents on existing compression
technology their implementation is based
on the deflate compression algorithm
which is a combination of lz77 and
huffman coding gzip is not the only game
in town and other formats like zip 7zip
and rar solve similar problems on the
web gzip is the most common way to
implement end-to-end compression where a
file is compressed on the server then
decompressed by the browser to reduce
the amount of data sent over the network
although broadly is a newer compression
algorithm that's generally superior for
files on the web to get started open up
any linux machine where you'll find gzip
installed by default as one of the most
popular utilities of the gnu project to
compress a file use the gzip command
followed by the file name that creates a
new file ending in gz that should be
significantly smaller run the command
again with the l flag to print out the
compression ratio the higher the ratio
the more space that was saved now use
the d flag to decompress the file back
to its original form or better yet use
the gunzip command in the real world
though you'll often want to compress
multiple files at the same time gzip on
its own cannot compress an entire
directory for that you'll need to bring
in an archiver like tar its name is
derived from tape archive and what it
does is take multiple files and combine
them into a single file known as a
tarball when running the tar command
include the z flag to automatically
compress the archive congratulations you
just made a large set of files smaller
this has been gzip in 100 seconds hit
the like button if you want to see more
short videos like this thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one